hey leute was klappt und jetzt
willkommen beim neuen video ich habe
heute das ja ziemlich langer zeit mal
wieder mein bruder mit dabei hat sich
keiner obwohl doch das habe ich schon
viele gewünscht dass wir mal wieder
zusammen wie du machen ich glaube das
letzte video was wir zusammen gemacht
haben da hatte ich auch keine ahnung
50.000 oder so also viele von euch
kennen ihn vielleicht auch gar nicht
schlecht war wie heißt du nochmal berlin
und wie lange ist das her dass wir schon
wieder mal gemacht haben
gelobt wurde sechs monate länger glaube
ich keine ahnung ist auch scheißegal wir
uns gedacht wir machen mal solle art
jetzt nicht challenge aber schon halt so
ich würde es ihn und zwar eigentlich
ganz einfach das prinzip haben uns beide
also fragen ausgedacht so er hat fragen
über sich er mir stellen und ich muss
die hand beantworten wenn ich falsch
liege
dann darf er mir eine clutch now als
gedacht so wir lassen das jetzt nicht
einfach so bei einer klatschen soll
wir nehmen doch nur teller dazu und zwar
darf man hier eingreifen und dann das
gleiche hab ich gemacht steckt ein stück
wer anfängt und dann weil wir nicht
lange lagern wenn ihr davon noch eine
zweite folge sehen wollt oder so oder
noch was mit ihm an könnt ihr jetzt
schon mal daumen nach oben da lassen
oder ist in die kommentare schreiben
keine ahnung und wir machen blickt nur
wenig gewonnen soll ich da anfang nicht
ob ich da anfangen
wir fangen an mit der ersten frage also
erste frage wie viele paar schuhe habe
ich gerade also schuhe die ich auch
wirklich tragen so jetzt nicht
irgendwelche die dann noch im regal aber
die schon seit zwei jahren nicht mehr an
alte 6955 viele denken wohl viele schuhe
obwohl ich habe gar nicht so viele
schuhe aber immer gleich ganz viele
teller sondern so so nicht so fest noch
nicht das wird von falsch waren wir
fragen falsch war der frage immer fest
so richtig behinderte uns ist halt nicht
eingefallen daten macht man so einen
scheiß dann habe ich angefangen fußball
zu spielen mit wieviel jahren die jugend
ein mini kicker ja/nein 56 einfach
richtig drauf okay was auch habe ich
mehr als 150 videos auf youtube pass auf
was auch junge glück habe ich mein
teppich voll
jetzt habe ich mehr als 100 videos auf
youtube blog ja das ist meine
lieblingsfarbe blau schwarz schwarz
schwarze junge fahrer junge ja was meine
lieblingsfarbe ist egal wann war das
fass auf dazu wann war ich das erste mal
besoffen 14
nein jetzt läutet euer leben so
heutzutage ist das war normal in der
jugend die mit zwölf schon bewährte
macht mit elf schon besoffen sind aber
ich weiß erst mit 15 man probiert das ja
immer mal aus so kein falsches bild von
mir weil ich noch nicht 16 war aber du
bist jetzt erst mal einen ins auge glaub
ich
sie ist einfach wann habe ich geburtstag
die junge stadt denn für eine frage bist
du ja selber schuld
dritter elfter 1902 1500 ca 2000 ich bin
dann pass auf die nächste frage ist sehr
auf mich bezogen was sagt ein bauer der
seinen traktor widmen zumal ja was sagt
ein bauer der sein traktor sucht dieses
total einfach mehr was sagt er baute er
sein tags also das ist so nicht auf dich
gezogen her und sagt man sollte aber was
sagt der suche mein traktor richtig
eigentlich sagt er wo ist mein traktor
aber von den witz lustig da hab ich
damit sagen ich würde meinen drei ecken
doch okay du bist was ist mein
lieblingsessen sozusagen pizza lasagne
du sollst ein zu sagen pizza lasagne hat
scheiße mehr macht oder schmilzt ich bin
so heißt das vielleicht alles runter
das hat voll gegenteil letzte frage
kommt von mir auf tausender gerundet wie
viele autos habe ich klar
circa auf 1000 gründe 218 1200 neben und
der fakt dass ich wohl kurz nach 218
1318 1554 das heißt wir wollen auf der
name in der dritten klasse ab 5 wird
aufgerundet zur teller
das schmerzt alles das wird alles runter
machen das schon wieder getroffen
aber nicht zornig deine käppi ist ein
scheiß alter ja leute das war's jetzt
erstmal mit den fragen könnt ihr auch
mal in die kommentare schreiben also
wenig zufolge machen soll dass auf jeden
fall mal daumen runter und schreibt
ihnen kommentare was wir uns denn beim
nächsten mal um die ohren pfeffern soll
und ja dann machen wir das ich würde
sagen sein instagram also findet ihr in
der video beschreibung wenn ihr da mal
vorbeischauen wollte wir müssen jetzt
ganz schnell weg weil es tropft und
wieder nicht so geil aus wie viel geld
kriegt wenn ich morgen so eine schule
wir etwas sagen zum abschluss ein toller
monat